I welcome the judgment this morning of
the Supreme Court that judgment is
unanimous that judgment is unambiguous
and that judgment is unqualified as you
all now know that judgment is that the
prorogation of parliament was unlawful
unlawful because it prevented or
frustrated Parliament in the discharge
of its core duties and it did so at a
crucial time for our country the
citizens of the UK are entitled to
expect that Parliament does discharge
its core functions that it is in a
position to scrutinize the executive to
hold ministers to account and to
legislate if it chooses in the light of
that explicit judgment I have instructed
the house authorities to prepare not for
the recall the prorogation was unlawful
and is void to prepare for the
resumption of the business of the House
of Commons specifically I have
instructed the house authorities to
undertake such steps as are necessary to
ensure that the House of Commons sits
tomorrow and that it does so at 11:30
a.m. I have contacted party leaders and
where that has not been possible senior
representatives of political parties
in order to inform them of my thinking
and to prepare the way for the House of
Commons to do its work
owing to notification requirements with
which I'm sure you're all closely
familiar it will not be possible for the
to be a Prime Minister's Questions
tomorrow however for the avoidance of
doubt there will be full scope for
urgent questions for ministerial
statements and for applications for
emergency debates understanding order
number 24 colleagues I thank you for
your interest and I hope you will agree
that the position is clear and
unmistakable good afternoon